[Music]
hi everyone I'm Andy Chang I'm a product
manager on Google's privacy and security
team really happy to be here today talk
to you a little bit about the lessons
we've learned from securing Google
miscarrying Google customers on Google
cloud so enterprises today are seeing an
increasing number of breaches and the
increasing number of breaches being
reported an increasing number of ways in
a larger scope in the public and this
trend does not seem to be decreasing on
day on a very regular basis the increase
in data that's sensitive data that's
being collected created combined with
the attackers increased determination
and skill is only going to make this a
larger and larger problem so at an
average an independent study showed that
enterprises see almost a million events
on a weekly basis and that reduces down
to more than three actual incidents that
need to be investigated potentially
remediated at Google it's very important
and we think it's very important to
think like the attacker
so the attackers have a particular kill
chain it's part of Google culture to do
red teaming on a regular basis and it's
also part of the informal culture to do
quite a bit of white Pat hacking well
these things allow us to really focus in
hone in on what the attackers are
actually focused in on and so in
thinking like the attacker the attackers
are focused really overall in trying to
target identities the code the data the
metadata and the resources on the
identities the typical things that get
compromised our user accounts or ooofff
tokens on the code side the injection of
malware the actually intersection with
even in the changing the binaries
introducing things into packages or
libraries on the data side just the
ability to kind of egress sensitive data
so they can use that for a range of
purposes and on the metadata to look for
enter the attack on cryptographic keys
and secrets and finally from the
resource standpoint the really looking
at attacking things from either a denial
of service basis or subverting
and abusing resources for the purposes
of creating a command and control
infrastructure or botnets or a
cryptocurrency mining so all these are
really kind of where the state of play
is today now at Google we've been very
fortunate to have eight of our services
reach out to over a billion users
including Google cloud as a result every
moment of every day we see the full
range of attacks that actually are going
on and the full range of bad actors so
we see thing anything from lone wolves
and script kiddies to nation state
actors to hacktivist groups trying to
attempt to do the range of attacks of
phishing denial of service malware
injections for the full range of
motivations could be economic
motivations espionage motivations or
just purely for fame as a result of that
we've had to evolve the culture and the
strategy for building security around
Google based on the global scale and
view of bad actors we get while
maintaining the pace that supports the
innovation that the core products within
Google need as a result of that
experience we've learned a few lessons
of how to secure Google and how to
secure Google customers and enable them
to secure themselves that we'd like to
share so there are about seven kind of
key highlights that we want to talk
about today and the first of those is
really defense-in-depth by default at
scale and that's protecting again those
three main issues we talked about the
identities the data in its three various
forms code user data and metadata and
then the underlying resources and then
trust through transparency so not only
is it necessary and important to always
have leading-edge technology in order to
build the trust with you as customers
and as partners we actually need to be
more and more transparent about the
security infrastructure that we have
automation of best practices so on the
development side the ability to take the
user out of the decision-making process
that take developers out of bespoke
creating things
actually automate the practices so they
get the best and most secure things by
default and then similarly a core part
of Google culture is being open and
sharing innovation and that's a core
part of the security culture we very
much believe that a safer web for all is
beneficial for the masses and for
everyone and our ability to take a
number of our innovations and either
open source them open standard them or
make them available as a public
increases and raises the is the tie that
raised a lot of boats on the user side
it's important to address
programmatically common use cases so
again that we take the user out of the
decision process and that common things
like patches and updates are clear
programmatically and by default finally
from a security standpoint in a public
cloud and customer environment it's
important for us to folks be clear about
where the shared responsibilities line
is and really do empower our customers
to deliver on their part of that
responsibility and lastly with all these
things in combination trust and security
can really be an accelerant to business
and so now I'm going to talk about a
bunch of these things in a bit more
detail so historically historically
historically users customers and
partners have really depended on the
network as that key barrier for security
and they really had a intellectual model
of the villains being kept outside and
then all the targets and things they
want to protect be kept inside but that
model is broken today with you either
someone gets inside or if someone starts
inside the wire they're fundamentally
from far fewer obstacles controls and
defenses for them and enterprises are
seen and seen that in their day to day
life as enterprises now perforate their
own perimeters to use cloud services to
allow mobile access this kind of core
perimeter model is broken now Google for
quite a while now we've not had a
perimeter base model we do not believe
that there is an abstraction allows you
to say there's an outside
inside in fact our solution is a
perimeter less model based on the fact
that we can do identity and
authentication and policy on each access
to every resource and we've talked about
that in our beyond court papers that
we've published over the last three to
four years a key part of that is that
many of the services Google delivers are
public to the public web by nature so in
order to keep a security level high
enough to protect the users using those
services we've had to build a defense in
depth at scale by default structure and
we'll talk about that infrastructure in
a moment so the first lesson integrate
the defense in depth at scale by default
at Google when we think about the
defence of our infrastructure we really
think about map to nine layers from
Hardware through secure boots -
inter-process communications and the
curated operating system - the storage
and data services and network that Eric
and Diane talked about earlier today
application level security deployment
operations and all data usage so at each
layer of these we've designed so that we
can have provenance and minimal trust
between each layer which allows us to
then know that as an application spins
up whereas the hardware spins up it's
built on an increasingly trusted and
known platform so that when it finally
operates its operating in the situation
where the write code is authorized by
the right service running on the right
machine accessing the right data at the
right time and in the right context
that's a core part of every operation
that occurs at Google to dive this in a
little bit more depth we're going to
talk about many of the layers that form
the underlying layers so at the hardware
level and we're very fortunately we have
large enough scale that we can build
purpose-built
hardware and that means from
purpose-built chips going into
purpose-built servers into purposeful
storage and their personal networking
into purpose-built and wholly owned data
centers that we operate globally after
we have the provenance therefore in this
apply chain of those servers the next
step is to boot in a trusted fashion so
we cryptographically sign the boot the
bootloader all the way up to the basic
kernel and therefore allows us to now
have a machine state which is in a known
good state with a deef a unique
cryptographic identity that then allows
us to determine that it's ready to be
joined to the fleet
once it's kind of at that point we also
have our own curated and hardened
version of KVM which we spent a lot of
time through both the code analysis
fuzzing and actually changes in
modifications of the code to make sure
that that's a secure core basis of our
hardware and software infrastructure we
have authentication and cryptographic
way between services at this low level
and then we want a curated image of Unix
again that's been stripped out percent
of Linux that's been stripped out of
many of the cano and vulnerabilities in
all these cases no developers we've
found we've also published back out to
the security community so that the world
and large can benefit from this so now
we're a point where we have trusted
Hardware it's boosted and trusted State
and the underlying host software is
something we have high confidence in at
a storage level we encrypt everything at
risk by default in one or more different
ways we have underlying obviously disk
encryption hardware description but on
top of that at an application layer for
all data accesses on Google Cloud we're
encrypted at rest we additionally
encrypt in transit between data centers
we own and we also allow that ability to
control the access and logging of the
data so through our set of audit logs
and also through set of internal logging
at the network layer as both Eric and
Diane pointed out this morning we have
one of the world's largest private
networks and what that means for
customers they can connect with us at
over a hundred different points of
presence across 33 countries and from
that point forward they're on a private
Internet private network completely off
the public Internet and we can guarantee
that end-to-end from where they touch
the point of presence to the actual
servers and systems that serve their
applications
in addition once you have the network in
place next piece is really the
applications the applications that we
build so within Google we have a
software lifecycle that programmatically
enforces peer review security review
privacy review before one line of code
is pushed to production and in addition
we use static code analysis on the our
source code combined with the ability to
look at and scan the libraries and the
packages they're linked in so that
throughout the build cycle in the
manifest we have a chain of evidence and
a binary signature that allows us to
know that our code that's about to be
deployed is actually the right code this
gets back into I said earlier about
making sure the right code is running on
the right machine which has an identity
authorized by the right service or user
who has my daddy with those right
permissions accessing the right data at
the right time in the right context once
we're through with from an application
development standpoint through the
software Providence through the ability
to actually actively scan that software
the next step is to deploy and at Google
we have a phrase that your first users
are typically abusers so there's always
the opportunity as soon as you deploy
code to see from a different set of ways
the attackers trying to find ways to
actually breach the actual software to
creating and their number of things we
do on the deployment side first for
users we enable them to have a hardware
phishing resistant two-factor
authentication we and we enforce that
all of our employees with access to
anything at Google use that same
hardware two-factor phishing resistant
security key in addition all Google
services are encrypted through TLS and
then Google as an overall infrastructure
has a Google front end which is globally
distributed at the different points of
presence but logically centralized and
that gives us the ability also to by
default have built in now a service DDoS
protection for a number of things like
sin fly a lot of the voltammetric
attacks and as a cloud customer if you
use one of the load balancers as product
you
also protected behind that as well as if
you use our platform of services such as
App Engine or bigquery or software
services like G suite
those are automatically protected by
from DDoS attacks in addition we've
invested in further in the actual
encrypting and certification of traffic
between endpoints through certificate
pinning which presents map proof
prevents man the middle attacks as well
as moving forward the work that we're
doing in an open way around certificate
authorities which allows you to have an
open record and make sure that if a
particular CA gets compromised that that
won't then be able to be injected in and
created another vector for folks so once
things are deployed now we have to
operate them and one of the core parts
of Google and our infrastructure is that
we have the underlying infrastructure
from the host side automatically patched
and updated and this is something that
customers don't have to provide
maintenance windows or see downtime for
us to do if they offer our live
migration because everything at Google
runs on a uniform substrate we're able
to live migrate user information around
while we're making either maintance
changes or importantly these patches and
updates that make sure everything stays
current in addition from an operation
standpoint we have our own threat
analysis team which focus in on the type
of attackers that we see targeting
Google the advanced persistent threats
looking at the full range of data we
have at Google and looking at the
signatures and the modes that they use
so that we can better protect ourselves
and our customers and our customers data
and we have both a pre fail team focused
on security engineering and proactively
and preventative ly securing our
applications as well as a post fail team
and instant response
focused on actually investigating and
taking those millions of events entering
those into deciding whether those are
instants that need to be explored or not
finally from a usage standpoint as the
applications B are used we have the
ability through again the data that we
collect to look at login reputation to
look at URL reputation in a preparation
and things like Android store so we get
a full sense of what actually is a
potentially a good binary versus a bad
binary what's good behavior versus bad
behavior and from a cloud a Google cloud
standpoint we provide audit logging for
both access logs as well as admin logs
so that you as a customer can see what's
also going on so as a part of this then
in addition to the technology that we've
put in here we've also continued to
invest in the people so we have seven
hundred plus software engineers and
security engineers solely focused on
securing Google and Google customers on
cloud and then it's the combination
really of the technology and the team
that continues to allow us to deliver
security at a high level standard in
addition if you want to learn more about
our infrastructure security design I
highly recommend that you intend Niels
Provos talk tomorrow at 5:30
it's session IO 243 and he'll go in even
more detail around our infrastructure
security so again the first lesson from
securing Google and Google customers is
it's important to have integrated
defense and depth that scale by default
which means that from an end end basis
you can establish provenance and you
know exactly what code you're running
and you know what you know insecure
state is so lesson 2 is in addition to
the technology we just talked about and
that's core right it's a necessary
condition to have leading technology
from security standpoint for you as a
customer and you as partners to trust us
we believe highly in trust through
transparency and what that means is that
it's a part of Google security culture
that whenever possible
we allow you as the customer and the
user to decide for yourself and have
visibility in what we're doing so you
can make decisions and draw your own
conclusions about how we're running
things and whether it's appropriate to
your business and some examples of this
are transparency report which gives on a
regular basis a view of how legal and
public actions affect sensitivity and
access to information on the Internet in
addition we have an ongoing a recurring
effort for increasing certifications so
that once again you can either inspect
yourself or you can trust
and invest in a third party that has
already validated what we do this spans
the full range of ISO 2120 700 127 oh 17
and 18 sock 1 2 & 3 FedRAMP for a number
of our services especially G suite the
ability to do model contract clauses
with customers and the ability also the
signed bas for HIPPA for a number of our
services and this is an area that we are
going to continually invest in and
increasingly invest in for the
additional certifications that are
prioritized by our customers matched to
what they need for their business and
also from a trust and transparency side
another piece of have this is aligned is
to the s AP announcement that we made
this morning as well with partnering
with sa P to deliver governance risk
management and compliance solutions and
also partnering with sa P so the sa P
can become a data custodian of data on
Google cloud the third lesson is really
around automating best practices to
prevent common mistakes at scale so as I
mentioned earlier us as humans are the
source of many of the potential issues
and problems and so from a development
side it's very important for us to
automate as much as possible and
abstract out the decisions and choices
our developers have to make that may
lead them to create a less secure state
as I also mentioned for most of our
services that we deployed in the public
are at the web application level so at
the l7 level so a common area of concern
and prioritization for us is in
cross-site scripting so as an example of
some of the automation that we've done
we have frameworks and we have secure
coding practices combine those with
automated scanning and what that's
allowed us over a four-year period is
reduced cross-site scripting errors by
over 30 percent and for some of our
billion user applications that's reduced
cross-site scripting vulnerabilities
down to near zero the fourth lesson and
this is again core to Google both from
an innovation open source standpoint is
really to share innovations to the wider
community and really raise the bar and
lift the tide so that the
web becomes most more secure for all
some examples of this you know Google
has for a long time been a contributor
to security and a leader in the
contributions of security
going back to TLS and the safe browsing
interface our vulnerability rewards
program which started back in November
of 2010 has to date paid out over nine
million dollars to security researchers
who have found various things and helped
us improve the security of our own
platform the security key technology
that I talked about in combination with
the phyto Alliance to again provide a
phishing resistant way that combines
from a user experience low effort and a
high security ability so that actually
will be used and secure our users and
employees project zero which is an
independent effort within Google which
looks for O'Day's and third-party
software and has been instrumental in
driving fixes to some of the key
vulnerabilities that we found and
recently over the last year are we've
actually open sourced our vendor
security framework to allow you to
actually take advantage of some of the
controls some of the ways we think about
things when we engage with vendors at
Google to actually allow access to our
Chrome fuzzer so that you can use the
infrastructure from a fuzzing standpoint
and also from an IOT beacon standpoint
to extend from an open format standpoint
a secure and privacy preserving beacon
format and the one thing also I'd
mentioned back in for our work in KVM
you know each of the bugs that we found
in the cavea we've actually again
externalize dand made available to the
security community so they can benefit
from that and I think today that's been
we found about over two-thirds the
actual publicized bugs that have been
found in KVM turf from a fifth lesson
standpoint it's also from an operational
standpoint to address calming use cases
programmatically and some of the key
examples of this is that while there's a
lot of press today around zero-days and
around very sophisticated advanced
persistent threats most of our customers
and most departments still have a lot of
potentially basic hygiene
security things that can be addressed
such as patching and updating and what
users do to secure themselves an example
of our philosophy around updates and
patching is this is the last three
versions of Chrome that have been
released over since September and
basically what you see on the x-axis is
the week in which the week by week of
the year and on the y-axis the
percentage of adoption so within the
first week of each of the launches or
updates what the majority of the 1
billion plus users are updated to the
new version and that's a core part of
both our chrome and Android approach and
also our approach to patching in our
underlying fleet is that it should be an
automated process it should happen by
default and therefore people get to be
secure by default without having to take
any additional effort piece the next
piece is focused again around users you
know as I mentioned before on the
development side us as humans are some
of the weakest links and similarly on
the user side users and phishing is the
most common way that breaches start and
again talking to one of the key
solutions that we helped bring to market
is really the efficient resistant
hardware two-factor you'll be hearing
more about that and the rest of this
conference and that's something that
again as employees of Google it's
required it's how we access and secure
ourselves to any access at Google and
something we highly recommend that the
admin accounts at any of the have you as
users or anyone on Google cloud also use
this phishing resistant two-factor
solution in addition you'll see most of
us at Google are also used Chromebooks
and Chromebooks are another way that by
default you can be secured by
Chromebooks have there's no way to
download software onto Chromebooks so if
you think about Hardware resisting
resistant to factor the ability to
eliminate the ability to install malware
on your machine on your machines those
are ways by default again that the
community in general can be more secure
and eliminate one of the easiest attack
vectors so lesson 6 really is around
empowering customers to fulfill their
responsibilities in the show
possibility model for security so for
most of you in the audience you're
probably very familiar with this this is
the 2011 Lockheed Martin kill chain for
attackers which really looks to provide
how the attackers think about ultimately
getting to their objectives but to date
there hasn't been a similar common view
of what the defender killed chain looks
like some of the initial work on that
has really focused really on Postville
right really on what happens between the
monitoring detecting the ability to
alert and then the actions they're after
if you break that out some more looking
at just the post fail piece work
recently at RSA from Microsoft has
further expanded some of the response
choices and giving us more processing
more framework around what folks do on a
response basis and if you look at the
original work from Lockheed Martin that
also really focused just on the response
side so what we can do to the attacker
kill chain to either detect it deny it
destroy it deceive it but the
traditionally most of these things have
come from the old world where a company
has full control of its data centers and
if infrastructure and really there's
only one organization that's involved in
handling any incident as we've now moved
to kind of public cloud and a
cloud-based world there are two things
that additionally need to happen one is
increased in addition to that kill chain
on the pre-fill side and having that is
an integrated part of the overall
decision on the defense side so in
addition to the post fail reaction how
do we together with our customers assess
and provide the right assessment the
attack surface how do we actually
specify define what the secure baseline
is and have that enforced across
on-premise hybrid and multi cloud and
then how do we protect those uniformly -
so there aren't any chinks in the armor
irrespective of what the infrastructure
is and then that feeds into the
protection detection alerting and
response and on the backend one key
thing that historically again has not
been focused on but is more and more
important is the communication aspect
historically when we talked about
Incident Response in detection response
it was again within one organization
and so that the sausage-making was
really hidden at this point in time when
customers have a shared responsibility
on cloud the distinction the
communication paths between the customer
and the cloud provider need to both be
programmatically and processed from a
standpoint evolved so they actually meet
the needs on both sides and the last
thing is really the opportunity to learn
so as both Diana and faith they talked
about this morning
you know we're in the age of machine
learning so the ability to take the data
that we now have across the cloud that
you have as customers and use that to
integrate both in learning on the
pre-fill side in the detection side and
the response side is a great opportunity
so what we want to do now then is
connect this defender kill chain this
extend defender kill chain with those
targets I talked about at the beginning
right so attackers are looking to get at
again identity code data metadata and
resources when you combine this you can
create a framework which really looks at
the intersection of the two both in pre
fail and post fail and now we can have a
very very clear discussion between cloud
providers and customers about where the
shared responsibility sits so some of
the key places the sits if you think
about where audit and appliance sit they
sit around in the pre fail assessment
and specifications phase that's what a
lot of audit and compliance is about in
addition security engineering sits in
similarly how to define from your
development cycle the things that make
your code and your system secure by
design when we cross over the post fail
side that's really historically been the
role of security operations the sock and
the detection response teams however one
thing you'll note perfectly is I haven't
created a overlap between those and that
reflects what life is like today but
that's one of the things that needs to
change as we think about how to do end
and security operations in similar to
how folks to ended up doing dev
development operations all right that
overlap of understanding what you
specify gets turned into what you
monitor for gets turned into what you
detect and what you're able to then
respond to and as I talked about before
there's a huge opportunity from the
learning
across all of these to feed into the
growth of this so let's take a
test-drive of this and practice and what
does this mean so key intersections
again audit and compliance security
around each of the things for example a
security engineering around identity as
that become a shared responsibility
around policy specification and
enforcement vulnerability management
data protection logging those are the
common topics that come up in the series
and from an operation side the
communication and learning pieces now
when we map this to identities what we
have here then just orange you is right
to left on premise through to software
service
so the abstraction the sense of control
for the customer is going most on the
right least on the left and then in the
y-axis the stages of the kill chain from
assess all the way down to learn the
color codes are what the provider
typically manages in these situations
versus on the green side what the
customer manages and then the yellow
gold areas are those opportunity areas
where even though this is a customer
responsibility and custom managed thing
theirs is where either providers or
partners can help the customer or
achieve their shared responsibility so
what does this mean in practice so from
an identity standpoint assessing the
strength of your identity and how your
identity solutions that's squarely on
the customer that's not something that
really cloud provider just decides but
enabling the cloud the customer to then
understand and specify what's the secure
baseline those are opportunities for the
cloud provider and/or partners to help
the customer understand what their
secure state is what the baseline is and
do the reference from that as you can
tell as you go from a
software-as-a-service where very little
is in the direct control of the customer
and the customer is really using
software created by the provider there's
a lot that's not the customers
responsibility in the platform as a
service case is where that gray area
there's a number of things in the
specified protects aside that end up
being the customers responsibility as
well as that in all cases that
opportunity to learn and where most the
folks doing traditional lift and shift
are obviously an infrastructure of
service and throughout the spectrum
besides just the assessment side of
identities the ability for the us as the
cloud provider or our partners to help
customers fulfill irresponsibility spans
the whole spectrum and including a
responsibility around the communication
and the underlying learning pieces and
this this kind of pattern is largely the
same from a data standpoint the
additional opportunity from a data
standpoint is that cloud providers and
what we talked about this earlier in
terms of a Content awareness have the
ability to also assist customers and
their ability to understand what data at
the content they have what the policies
they are and I'll talk more about that
and finally from a resource standpoint
so if you're talking the underlying
resources to deliver services software
is a service basis for example something
like drive or Gmail the customer really
doesn't have responsibilities to protect
those resources those are Auto scaled
resources that the cloud provider is
managing similarly in a platform as a
service but these are operationally
things that the cloud provider provides
once you move to infrastructure as
service throughout the full spectrum as
a cloud provider and with our partners
we have ability to assist you as a
customer about how you want to run and
secure your resource infrastructures
whether it's against denial of service
whether it's against abuse and those
type things so kind of the last lesson
is to take that shared responsibility
model and talk about what does that mean
for creating a trusted underlying
infrastructure for you as a customer and
there's really focused around three
things context aware access so getting
back to what we talked about within
Google we do the right code is running
on the right machine authorized by the
right user running at the right time and
in the right context being able to
externalize that for you as customers to
you be the same type of access control
that you guys provide from a content
aware standpoint the ability to not only
look at data and think about the
encryption of it but also think about
the classification of it and also
differentially both specify and enforce
policy against that data is an
opportunity that exists now in the
public cloud as data gets moved to that
that's much harder for you guys to start
in practice and your existing on-prem
infrastructures and lastly platform
trust and we'll talk a little bit more
about where we're thinking further on
the platform trust side so you know
trust and security historically had been
looked at as things that slow down
innovation you know our firm belief at
Google and something that we've lived
through keeping up with the velocity of
our production teams is that once you
have the right set of trust and security
by default you actually accelerate
innovation because that allows
developers to focus on their kind of
core practice which is delivering and
building great applications the drive
business and that the underlying
infrastructure protects them and
protects their applications and Eric
talked about this earlier in the keynote
that is the model that we were using
Google that's the model that we think
will in the long term be the right one
for folks building building businesses
in order to do that the three components
that we see really are context to where
secure access so really extending beyond
this perimeter model to allow individual
resources to have policy applied at the
moment of use against their identity
content-aware data management so as you
all know the nature of the data what's
actually in the data typically dictates
its risk so being able to make users and
customers more easily aware of what that
content is and manage that so they can
manage the differential policies and
from a platform trust standpoint the two
kind of key principles one we talked
about before which is the trust through
transparency the more we're able to show
you and have you validate what we do the
higher level of trust that you'll have
and ability to run your businesses on
our platform and also enabling minimal
required trust so how do we increase the
portfolio of items that you can choose
to do without even having to trust
Google or the cloud provider so these
are the areas that we're looking at kind
of moving forward so kind of in summary
defense-in-depth
is really around allowing the
infrastructure to be secured by default
and then allowing users developers
clients and partners to really focus on
what they do best which is creating
what's next in building biz
the trust to transparency piece enables
you to see and verify for yourself and
therefore make decisions in the form Rey
about whether you want to run certain
business processes and workloads on
certain configurations automation
abstraction takes humans out of the
process and creates repeatability and
deliver ability at scale our core values
around open sourcing and sharing
innovation are really around uplifting
the whole internet and making it safer
for everyone and then from the user
standpoint to take again that decision
making choice out of things like updates
patching access so that the common use
cases are addressed programmatically and
folks are secured by default empowering
customers to secure themselves so being
clear about the shared responsibility
model enabling kind of a successful
shared responsibility by providing a
full range of services that allow
customers to deliver on their part and
lastly to accelerate and continue to
create use security as an accelerant the
ability of focus on context awareness
content awareness and then platform
trust so you know a core part of where
we are as an enterprise working with
enterprises is not only to enable you to
kind of get to where you want to go but
to start with meeting you where you are
and then taking you about where you want
to you can imagine
[Music]
you